j'accueille aujourd'hui deux des co
fondatrice du groupe d'entr'aide contre
le racisme envers les asiatiques du
québec julie tran et l'oral
julie trang est aussi candidate à la
maîtrise en service social des limaces
et de parois et l'oral ou est aussi
actrice ait repris ce bonjour madame non
j aurais dame je vous accueille sur une
triste nouvelle
avant-hier mardi huit personnes dont six
femmes d'origine asiatique ont été tués
rappelant pas aux états unis la police a
indiqué que si on avait pas de motif
haineux ou raciste
comment est vécue ce drame au sein des
communautés asiatiques ici au québec et
au canada
il est clair que le drame il est pour
tout le monde pas pour ces communautés
tout d'abord c'est sûr que la communauté
est en deuil premièrement c'est quand
même 6 millions qui ont dieu quitté
également beaucoup d'indignation depuis
les heures qui ont suivi donc c'est sûr
avec la situation dans l'immédiat on
reçoit de plus en plus de formations qui
en heureux on a vu aussi que le chef de
la police sont en attente a sorti un
communiqué
et celui ci a mentionné que le tueur
avait une mauvaise journée c'est le
jaune et le cas mais non sans quelques
faire cette tuerie puis en même temps
ils ont amené la situation comme si
c'était un problème d'addiction liés sur
le plan sexuel
donc dire que c'est ainsi que
s'additionnera même justement message
que c'est un problème de santé mentale
et quand justement un crime qui a été
émis à l'endroit des communautés fatigué
et si les communautés asiatiques s'amène
en sort justement qu'il n'y a pas de
responsabilité parle parle à personne
que fait cette tentative et qui a tué
pendant les six femmes ont étalé une
victime justement on peut on doit se
questionner pourquoi ces années de cette
façon le parce que au final nous ne
ferons notre communauté ça a été un
crime est nu c'est quand même des
dépisteurs de match que les
entrepreneurs étaient des femmes
asiatiques dans cete des personnages
atypiques travailler leur si un quartier
aussi que ces prédominant de personnes
asiatiques qui lui vient à l'intérieur
donc ce n'est pas un cas isolé et en
parler comme ça
un cas isolé enlève justement tout
l'enjeu du raciste mais qui est toujours
à l'endroit des communautés asiatiques
en effet peut-être on se dit que aux
etats unis c'est peut-être une situation
sociale qui est particulière
contrairement au canada toutefois il
faut comprend que il s'est passé
également des 60 similaire au québec par
exemple il ya eu des mosquées lieu
justement étudiants et donc c'est sûr
que ça a écrit vraiment beaucoup de par
chez plusieurs personnes asiatiques car
on sait que ça peut être un incident qui
pourrait arriver au québec est vraiment
de plus en plus les jeunes hommes de
sortir dans la rue parce qu'on va
pouvoir les violences alors à l'écart
des comités asiatique deviennent de plus
en plus violents que pensez-vous du
traitement médiatique des événements
d'atlanta ce que vous pensez qu'il ya un
biais contre les personnes d'origine
asiatique comprendre que c'est des
personnes qui travaillent dans
l'industrie du sexe tout ça est ce qu on
est dans cette logique totalement je
pense qu'il ya un biais plus qu'effacé
important la manière justement comment
les médias vont amener le sujet avant
maintenant les titres souvent ils vont
justement essayé de dédramatiser la
situation à l'endroit justement du tueur
tandis qu'ils vont pas descendre des fon
mais que les victimes sont des femmes
d'origine indienne c'est qu'ils vont pas
mettre le contexte où qui sera arrivé
justement ce que tu écris le et donc à
prévoir que ça église et billy justement
le rend si ça les corps des communautés
asiatiques dans l'amérique du nord
c'est la même chose aussi dans nos
médias arrivent pas quand c'est sorti la
nouvelle hier
aucun média à part les médias
anglophones à médias anglophones parler
de ce sujet l'offre qui est quand même
un drame or quand même assez très
violents à l'endroit des communautés
asiatiques et ça vraiment créé beaucoup
d'indignation et je trouve que justement
éviter bises et participatif justement
aux racistes envers les communautés
asiatiques vous vous organisez ce
dimanche seule une manifestation en
soutien à ses victimes
oui nous on organisa allait justement de
mettre mes ku qui est de l'organiste des
cheminots a progressé au québec
la première partie c'est vraiment une
marche pour dénoncer les violences et
violences racistes à l'égard des
communautés asiatiques parce que ça fait
un nom
justement on est dans cette pandémie est
vraiment les violences d' acte raciste
l'écrivain nul sur gagnent vraiment de
plus en plus violents ça ne serait que
le peuple est donc pour nous c'est un
moyen justement pour se mobiliser tous
ensemble pour dénoncer la situation
puis on va à lille rejoint organise
justement qui travaillent auprès des
travailleuses du sexe l'organisme stella
afin justement de faire une vie j'ai le
coming commémorative pour dénoncer
justement toutes les oppressions que ça
touche auprès des travailleuses du sexe
parce que souvent c'est elle c'est elle
qui reçoit le peu d'êtres par le
gouvernement c'est qu'ils sont le plus
marginalisé eux que leurs droits sont
souvent bafoués droit du travail droit
humain qui justement cosmin et que
c'était les travailleuses du siècle on
relève justement ce côté humain de chez
elle comme oui c'est est l'étrange
justesse mais aussi et des femmes
c'était des maires des soeurs elles ont
d'autres titres au-delà justement de ce
titre de travailleur est donc toute leur
aspect humain et est enlevé ça vraiment
saisi mon analyse pardon justement ces
personnes et vous n'avez pas pardonné
vous il ya une année au début de la
pandémie la cobi 19 vous avez fondé le
groupe facebook dont 13 contre le
racisme envers les asiatiques du québec
pourquoi vous l'avez lancé ce groupement
j'ai créé le groupe marque 20 c'est le
début de la pandémie le début de
confinement il y avait une hausse des
incidents à caractère raciste mais avait
du vandalisme dans les pagodes à
montréal j'avais aussi une personne
d'origine coréenne qui se met à regarder
à angie est aussi j'avais vu
beaucoup d'incidents des insultes
publiques à l'égard des personnes
d'origine asiatique sur différents murs
de mes amis de facebook
il y avait pas à ce moment-là d'endroits
où on pouvait regrouper tous les
accidents laa est aussi j'étais enfoncé
de natalité donc l'événement mais ça me
faisait peur de voir tous incident est
de voir tous ces accidents laa et de
sortir avec mon enfant j'avais vraiment
pas donc c'est pour ça que j'avais
besoin d'un groupe créé ce groupe là
pour pouvoir m'identifier il faut sortir
un peu de mon l'isolation parce que vous
vous consacrez beaucoup d'anxiété et ça
peut affecter la santé mentale et la
santé mentale c'est parce que j'ai
extrêmement tabou d'entre eux est
asiatique
donc c'est vraiment important pour moi
d'avoir ce groupe là pour pouvoir
regrouper tout c'est un accident à un
même endroit pour pouvoir parler
discuter de la santé mentale entre les
gens de notre communauté et il respire
et pardon est-ce que et est-ce que vous
depuis ce temps là c'est ce que les
incidents ils sont aussi en baisse au
mois par rapport à votre sondage locales
sur votre page c'est ce qui arrive parce
qu'avant il y en avait zéro incident
avant les incidents n'était pas
rapportée il faut savoir aussi dans les
commentaires de critiques alors ce qu'on
a une agression de type d'incident et ne
leur apporte pas parce que on a une
culture du silence où on veut ignorer le
problème signification qu'on a de la
part de nos parents qui disent que si
jamais on a un micro agression où on
voit soit en excluant ainsi tout comme
il faut juste qu'on est juste mouvement
continue à avancer dans la vie et ne pas
trop tarder nous et ne pas trop
s'attarder mais cependant la différence
avec la pandémie c'est qu'on était en
confinement isolement l'isolation
faisait en sorte que sacrées et ça crée
une part encore plus grande parce qu'on
pouvait pas de partager de façon avec
nos amis par exemple
et dites-moi est-ce que les jeunes
réagissent différemment des parents par
rapport aux incidents racistes des gens
qui ont été élevés ici parce qu'ils ont
une approche différente
il est jeune je suis né à montréal
les personnes qui sont québécois
d'origine asiatique
on a reçu une éducation qui est ici donc
on a un mix de valeurs québécoises et
une identité aussi à dia c'est donc
froid qu'il fait vraiment beaucoup plus
important pour nous de s'exprimer
on s'identifie oui à notre culture
adaptés à l'éducation aux parents qui
disent qu'il faut pas trop en parler
pour faire trop de bruit à propos de ça
cependant on est rendu à un point
surtout avec la pandémie est la hausse
des accidents raciste ou c'est important
de le dénoncer
et c'est pourquoi la raison pourquoi
j'avais créé le groupe parce que je
crois que notre comité savait pas
comment le dénoncer et on devait
informer les gens sur dénoncé à quelle
organisation à la police ou encore par
exemple pour pouvoir les utiliser pour
baisser le niveau de peur qu'on avait au
sein de la communauté pour moi je n'ai
ajouté en effet justement dans une
communauté si difficile de pouvoir le
dénoncer à qui on a vu que des chiffres
de sortir par justement le rapport du
spvm
il faut savoir que c'est schaeffler
n'est qu'un dessus de l'as berck
justement parce que comme le renommer
ses tabous et pourquoi c'était à vous
parce que nous n' est de 1 à une
barrière de langue dont ils sont
capables de dénoncer souvent les enfants
qui sont nés ici ce sont les enfants
traducteurs dont qui comprennent pas
nécessairement la situation qu'est ce
qui est arrivé est souvent ils vont être
présente
on pourrait d'abord que cannes et leurs
parents et essayer de pouvoir expliquer
à l'appeler mais en même temps ça peut
faire une traduction un réel de caisse
qui était arrivé et aussi nos aînés ont
cette mentalité cette falloir le que
quand ici il dénonça offre du poids de
plus au sein de nos sociétés ne veux pas
être un fardeau pour la société
vraiment c'est pour ça que c'est
d'éviter de croiser des équipes
extrêmement face et pour les personnes
qui veulent attaquer les gens de la
communauté et les femmes également sont
beaucoup plus vulnérables car souvent 2
l'image de la femme c'est perçu beaucoup
générale et de 2 seulement les femmes
pourquoi vouloir dénoncer car celles ci
doivent pas au nord justement de la
famille et si elle dénonce ça veut
briser cette image là et donc c'est sûr
qu'au niveau des valeurs c'est très
confrontant lorsqu'il est temps d'aller
dénoncer et donc on le sait que au sein
de notre groupe facebook beaucoup de
monde pour des témoignages et nous on en
reçoit de manière quotidiennement je
pensais bien au début laurence avait
vraiment beaucoup
et donc on sait que les chiffres qui
sont présentés les statiques sont
présentes et son contraire est miné le
questionnement mois tous a ajouté que
les chiffres qui sont qui sont compilés
par l'aspect bmc ceux qui ont été
dénoncés ça ne complique pas les
chiffres que par exemple nous les
témoignages qu'on reçoit sur le groupe
mais aussi on reçoit des témoignages
personnels c'est-à-dire qu'ils étaient
envoyés de façon personnelle qui ne sont
pas publiques sur le groupe
donc tout ce ne sont pas nécessairement
compilé parce que toutes ces personnes
ne vaut pas nécessairement leur apporter
à la sbm ou à des organisations
reconnues comme le croire l'ambition du
coup j'ai comme l'impression que le
racisme anti asiatique qui les a vu le
dans l'angle mort des luttes
antiracistes
est ce que je me trompe sur ce pont
blanc puis totalement souvent notre
leurs assistants vie stepan active et
voir normalisée puis c'est sûr que dans
les lieux d'une part c'est parce que
comme on l'a expliqué il tousse et du
côté me qui se passe au sein même de
communautés mais aussi souvent dans lors
des tables rondes lors des prises de
décision il ya peu de personnages ati
qui sont présents et souvent si on
regarde par exemple au niveau politique
on a extrêmement peu et d'hommes à cause
de cela c'est sûr que lorsqu ils tendent
à les dénoncer
c'est très difficile de mettre de
l'avant nous lutte qui aussi on sait que
c'est mi mai 2009 des modèles qui se
passe c'est même qui touche auprès d'une
communauté et donc c'est difficile de le
préciser également inquiet des frictions
à l'endroit de départ du var communautés
racisées et je pense que justement c'est
dû à la création de ce discours de
mythes des minorités modèle qui a été
construit par l'émetteur dans l'or des
droits tv que lorsqu'on recul sur le
plan historique et donc aujourd'hui la
nouvelle
génération qui est conscient de ces
histoires là ne veut plus répéter la
même chose
et qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire c'est
justement ils vont aller combattre ce
mythe des minorités modèle est il
vraiment ils vont créer des ponts avec
les autres communautés en participant
lors qui s'est passé dans la classe
mareuil à beaucoup de personnes
d'origine asiatique sont descendus dans
les rues afin de pouvoir offrir ces
têtes car telle est donc je pense à moi
de plus on peut sans cris dé nouveau
pont pour créer ce nu pour recréer le
lien de confiance qui se passe au sein
des autres communautés et on va aussi
les communautés asiatiques tous en vue
qu'on est pas un groupe homogène il faut
pas oublier merci beaucoup julie tran et
l'oral où je rappelle que vous êtes deux
des co fondatrice du groupe d'entr'aide
contre le racisme envers les asiatiques
du québec merci pour votre participation